we are asked to plot eight comma ten so
the first point the first number in this
ordered pair this is our x coordinate
this tells us how far do we move in the
x direction it's a positive eight so we
move eight in the x direction so we move
eight in the x direction and then the
second point or the second number in our
ordered pair is 10. that is our y
coordinate that tells us how far we move
in the y direction since it's positive
we move up 10. so we move up 10 all the
way over here and you could have thought
about it either way you could have said
hey look this is our y-coordinate this
is 10 so i could move up 10 and then my
x-coordinate is positive 8 so i'll move
8 along the positive x-axis or i'll move
eight to the right you see right over
here i have moved eight to the right one
two three four five six seven eight and
i have moved ten up one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten you might
be tempted to move 8 up and then 10 to
the right which would put you there but
then you would have had the two numbers
mixed up you would have had the x and
the y coordinates mixed up the 8 tells
you how far to move in the horizontal
direction the 10 tells you how far to
move in the vertical direction
let's do a couple more of these
plot 6 comma 10
well once again in the the first number
in the ordered pair is the x coordinate
how far we move in the x direction
so we move 6 to the right and then the
second number the 10 tells us our our
vertical coordinate our y coordinate so
it's positive 10 so we move 10
10 up
let's do one more
5 comma 7.
so my horizontal coordinate is 5 so i
move 5 to the right
and then my vertical one is 7 or my y
coordinate is 7. so i move seven up one
two three
four five six seven and as long as you
remember which one is horizontal and
which one is vertical or which one is
the x coordinate which one is the y you
should be fine you could say hey look
this is my y coordinate seven so i'm
going to move 7 up and my x coordinate
is 5 so i'm going to move 5 to the right
it will get you to that exact same point
this specifies exactly one point in the
coordinate plane